I am very seriously considering keeping
this look going for the whole review and
I thought better of it so baby driver I
have now seen it the latest film by
Edgar Wright and I'm going to be getting
into spoilers pretty quickly so the
spoiler free review I enjoyed it a lot
it was a lot of fun Edgar Wright movies
always are it's well made it is
energetic it is a good time if I were to
rank it it is not on par with the three
films of the Cornetto trilogy I'm still
debating where I feel it is relative to
Scott Pilgrim I haven't quite landed on
that one yet but it's still a very good
time I'm going to get right into
specifics and some of these would be
considered spoilers so if you wanted to
spoiler free that was it so as far as
spoiler stuff goes um I don't know I'll
just say it as they going on but
obviously I mean the music's kind of the
elephant in the room this this movie
both the movie and the character of baby
are the embodiment of that feeling you
get and when you put on earbuds and
you're just going through something with
us walking down the street doing the
dishes whatever listening to music it's
like you're in a little bubble you just
start doing things to the beat this
movie this character is the cinematic
embodiment of that feeling and it
captures it very very well
pretty much right out the gate through
the entire rest of the film and that's
an infectious fun feeling the leader act
on this Ansel Elgort he has got a really
great presence because he had he has to
make you care about this character and
bond with this character and like this
character despite saying very little
often having fun glasses on so you can't
really get a look at his eyes and is
almost in a constant level of some
degree of distraction because he's
always got his music going so through
all that he still has to be likable and
and someone that you can relate to and
he does that and it's impressive
honestly for as unshown we apart as it
is and there were way showy your parts
in this movie he grounds this whole
thing really well the supporting cast is
a lot of fun especially the other
criminals on there's Kevin Spacey who's
just doing that great
smarmy smartass thing that he had oh so
very good ass also on Jamie Foxx Jamie
Foxx does Jamie Foxx gives good crazy
and I kind of wish he'd do it a little
bit more often but yeah that's that
solid work from him a surprise for me a
little bit was Jon Hamm it's a snot like
I don't have a lot of expectations out
of Jon Hamm but I really liked where
things went because he seemed like the
more affable member so I absolutely did
not peg him as final boss fight material
but there you go and he makes it work as
you watch him and I mean Kevin Spacey
Jamie Foxx they're more intimidating on
site Jon Hamm becomes more intimidating
as the thing goes along until it's
actually quite satisfying that it ends
with him at the end there let me James
doesn't find she and Nelson Elgort have
really or Ansel L got to say baby I've
got a butcher of this guy's name
otherwise if I haven't already but Lily
James I'm playing the character of
Deborah and baby they have great
chemistry and they work well together
which is good because her role in the
story is largely functional now I have a
tendency to rail against romantic
subplots
in movies because I feel the bathroom or
majority of the time they're not
necessary and don't add anything this
time I do think it mattered that it was
there because it's important that baby
is not just running away from his old
life but he's also running to was
something else and she very much
represents that and like I said they
good enough chemistry that has sold it I
think it was maybe a little bit too much
time spent on it maybe not in total but
like there was a stretch after baby is
supposedly gotten out and he's done his
last job except that were only like 40
minutes into the movie so we know it's
not his last job yet this this extended
that just kind of keeps going and
because you know he's going to get
dragged back into it you I was getting
impatient for it to get there after
while I think overall and the the
tail-end felt a little longer than it
should've as well I think the
for all the movies probably about ten
minutes longer than it needs to be um I
was I was never bored there was one
thing that Edgar like movies are not and
that is boring so that was definitely
not the case but there were a couple of
sections that could have stood to be
trimmed down a little bit the driving
since this is a you know driving a
getaway movie the trappings awesome I
mean the stunts are great there's a lot
of group there's a lot of good foot
chases as well there's some decent
gunfights and then the music makes all
these things more fun than they already
are I think the thing about this film
ultimately for me and the reason that
even though it is quite good and while
we're seeing it was playing near you but
the reason it's sort of on the lower end
for me for Edgar Wright films is I think
because it's probably his least
ambitious in terms of the broad strokes
of the story concept and the themes
being dealt with however it's also
probably one of his most ambitious in
terms of execution and nailing every
specific beat that he was planning to
have so the the groundwork in the
foundational material I think is
probably the least engaging he's worked
with but he does still spend some really
great stuff out of it so yeah I guess
that's pretty much where I land this
baby driver is a real good time authors
probably still going to turn up in my
top ten of the year I'm going to confess
to being slightly disappointed but
that's only because I hold a go right to
a really high standard that he himself
has set so that's I mean that's just
relative so if like Edgar rates one of
your favorite directors of all times
maybe just I didn't go in expecting good
work you will get good work but like I
said I don't think it's on par with the
Cornetto trilogy but then again very few
things are so yeah you almost have to
kind of put those in a box and leave
them separate but it's a good time and
as I said if it is playing near you and
you haven't seen it yet give it a look
if you have seen it what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it don't forget to Like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at council of
geeks give a listen to the council of
geeks podcast available on itunes and
stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]